hi guys welcome to lesson number four in
this lesson we're going to be talking
about using python to build AI agents
for construction this lesson is going to
start easy it's going to start with just
an intro to Python and gradually build
upon that knowledge and by the end of
this you'll be able to build your own
autonomous AI
agent so let's take a quick look at what
we're going to cover in this lesson so
we're going to start off with a quick
introduction to python this is all going
to be via demonstration you're going to
be asked to follow along and code some
of the things as we're going so we're
going to do scripts and algorithms data
structures and finally open source
libraries so we're going to build on
code that's already in existence all of
this is going to be designed for
complete beginners then we're going to
talk about apis how we can fetch data in
real time from other sources of
applications on the internet and we're
going to talk about inter interacting
with large language models something
known as AI model inference where we're
going to send data to a large language
models VI an API we're going to receive
information back and we're going to do
stuff with
it this is all going to lead to us at
the end of this lesson basically coding
our own autonomous AI agent we're going
to build an app for estimating
quantities and doing material uh
takeoffs from CAD PDF drawings
automatically so you can essentially
upload a PDF CAD drawing and it's going
to do a bill of quantities for you from
the drawing itself so without further
Ado let's dive into
python okay so what I want you to do is
go on to the civil's AI training
resources notion page and I want you to
come down to Lesson Four from here I
want you to open up the cheat sheet and
from within here I want you to start
looking at this first section what we're
going to do here is get our environment
on our computer whether or not using a
Mac or Windows whatever system you're
using we're going to set it up first so
that we can start coding if you already
know that you can run uh notebooks duper
notebooks on your computer don't worry
you can skip this bit skip ahead but
this is for people who have not
installed uh python before on their
computer and haven't used um one of the
coding uh software like vs code so yet
so I'm going to explain how to get set
up so firstly what we're going to do is
we're going to go over to vs code uh the
website this is some software from uh
Microsoft actually and it's one of these
very popular um software for running
code and writing code um it's a software
that's very good at doing all of this so
it's built by Microsoft whenever you see
people on TV or in movies coding they
always have this like different colored
uh code with a black background usually
so this is the system that we're going
to use to write our code so what I want
you to do is go ahead and download
whichever version you need if you don't
already have it and I want you to get
this set up on your computer there are
other there are other options out there
so if you prefer something other than
Visual Studio code there's something
else there's other uh tools that you can
use but in this example this is the one
I use and a lot of people use it so I'm
going to base everything on vs code but
feel free to follow along with whatever
you have um once you've actually got
this installed I want you to come back
to the notion um page and I want you to
then install python so what I've got
here is instructions on how to do that
um in chat GPT so you know chat GPT is a
very good resource for telling you how
to actually do anything coding related
or um installing things like this so if
you have a Mac OS you can basically do
it via something called Homebrew which
is um a way for like managing all of
these uh different environments that you
have on your computer um and installing
different libraries so once you have
that installed you can do Brew install
Python and this will update uh
update um you know install the latest
version of
python you then for Windows you can
basically go to the official website and
download and install this um and just
basically run it like you'd install any
other software and the key key thing
here is go to the command prompt and
just check that you've got it installed
by typing in Python version if you're on
windows so very simple just to get in
Python installed you need this um then
what we're going to do is go back to our
notion and what we want to do is we want
to download the files we need for this
lesson so I want you to go to Lesson
Four I want you to download this ZIP
file um I then want you to get this file
from your downloads and maybe you can
just put it on your desktop first unzip
it you know and then I want you to put
this onto your desktop so we're going to
be working from this lesson four
throughout this um throughout this
lesson and um this contains the files
that we're going to be using so right
now don't don't worry about these right
now but the these are the files that
we're going to be using for this lesson
next I want you to go back to your
notion page and read the next
instruction so what I want you to do is
open up uh this folder in vs code so I'm
going to go down to my vs code over here
I'm going to open it up for the first
time and I'm going to go to um file and
then I'm going to go to Open folder
you might if you're opening this for the
first time you might have to do
something else you might have to get
signed in perhaps with your account but
after you've got signed in you should be
brought to a page which looks like this
you can then go to Open
folder and from here I want you to go to
document uh desktop and I want you to go
to Lesson Four just click Lesson Four
and then click open and this is going to
open that location so what you should
see here you should see those three
files which we just uh unzipped from our
um the notion page these three files in
here on the left and this screen should
be blank basically here on the left or
you might have this default page but you
can actually close this if you want um
next thing I want you to go up to
terminal and I want you to click new
terminal so don't do anything with this
just now but this is basically a command
line so when your there's two options
really when you're using uh Mac or
Windows or any computer usually use the
GUI the graphical user interface you
have a desktop you have like search all
of this your different apps but what um
usually is preferred when you're coding
is to do things from the command line so
in some ways this can make things a lot
faster or easier and you can execute
codes from here to do things so uh we'll
be working a bit from this command
command line in here and that's in the
terminal so let's go back to the notion
page and just finish up here so with inv
vs code um we're basically running
something called Jupiter notebooks so if
you've not used this before this is
basically a lightweight way of executing
Python scripts um it's very easy to get
started with these it's just like a a
file um the key thing here is this is
the file extension for it and when I
open it up it looks a bit like a um
it looks just a bit like a a sort of um
almost like a document where you can
write um you can write away in here and
you can uh execute the code either run
all or you can do some other types of
execution on this code and so this is a
very lightweight and easy way to start
working with python so we're going to be
using jupit notebooks a lot in this
lesson so um just make sure that you
you're set up exactly how I've set
things up
here okay next thing I want you to do is
I want you to go over to your notion uh
training page and I want you to uh
continue reading so here we're saying
that um basically we're going to be
using chat GPT to help us code what
we're going to do here is I'm going to
leave in this uh notion links to
different blocks of code which I'm going
to be using you can also ask some
follow-up questions in that chat GPT
conversation and you can see how it's
explaining these different blocks of
code we're going to be using so the
first section of this uh lesson that
we're going to be talking through for
python is for scripts and algorithms so
if you can click this link here what
this is going to do is it's going to
take us to um chat GPT conversation with
some different um let's say beginners uh
blocks of different scripts which we're
going to run through and understand um
the important thing with chat GPT is to
always double check these blocks of code
which is actually giving to you not just
assume everything it gives you is
correct cor because especially with like
more complicated
requests some of the Cod could give you
uh could be wrong so very important to
double check everything it gives you uh
what I'm going to do here is I'm going
to copy this block of code and I'm going
to go back to our Visual Studio code to
our Jupiter notebook uh and what you
need to do here is um paste this paste
this block in and before we run it what
might happen is you might not have a
python environment set up
so if that's not the case and you go to
click run all and an error message comes
up here what you can do is you can
actually select a version of python that
you want to use um the version I'm using
here is 3.10 so I'd recommend choosing
that one um for uh running it and um
yeah what I'm going to do here is I'm
going to click run all so you see here
it took very it was very fast and what
it's done is just printed out hello
world so this um function here this is
able to take um a string which is a
sentence or a collection of different
words and it's going to print that out
so here it's printing this back out into
our into our Jupiter notebook so hello
world so it's like we've brought this to
life now um what I'm going to show you
next is another one so here I'm going to
add another block of code so the idea
here is you can read this almost like a
book or a document so you can scroll
down and I'm I've added another block of
code just below this so what I'm going
to do now is I'm going to take this next
block which helps us to understand
variables and data types so I'm going to
do is I'm going to copy this and I'm
going to talk you through exactly what's
happening
here so in Python what we're doing here
is we're taking variables um and we're
giving them uh different number so this
would be one variable integer uncore
variable we're giving this the integer
value of 10 float variable so we're
giving this a value of 20.5 a float is a
decimal point number a string variable
so this is again words a sentence um so
we're giving this here um with the and
the way you DeMark this is with the uh
uh
semicolons and then we're saying here
Boolean so this is either true or false
um and this is another variable we're
given giving here
we can then print these again using the
same approach so we use the print
function um saying uh this is a form of
like called concatenation where we're
taking some string we're taking another
variable and we're um actually turning
these into a data structure so if I
click up here run all what we're going
to see is we're saying integer is 10
float is 20.5 string is hello Boolean is
true so what we're doing is printing out
different variables which we're storing
here you can actually also do some
manipulation of these variables so what
I could do is take my integer variable I
could take my float variable and I could
let's say create another line down here
which is print um let's do a division
so
um and you see I've basically got some
uh Microsoft Co co-pilot doing Auto
complete on my uh lines of code so here
it already kind of knows roughly
probably what I'm doing but I don't want
to do this exactly I wanted to take this
float variable and I want to do an
integer divided by a float and let's see
what this returns back to me so the idea
here is I can also use this as a
calculator so with python I'm
associating different uh different
information with different um variables
and then I can use these variables in
calculations so let me run this again
you're seeing division is um yeah giving
me this very long number here I can
actually do more with this I could
actually like round this if I want to
the result but I'm just going to leave
this how it is for
now let's create a new block of code and
let's go back to chat GPT and see this
next operation so what we're actually
doing here is more complicated uh
calculations so we're looking at other
other um methods so here we have um we
associating a with five B with three and
what we're doing here is addition so A+
B 5 + 3 can you guess what this will be
um so we're saying addition is going to
be eight subtraction is going to be two
multiplication 15 Etc so you see here
this is a way that in which you can use
python as just a simple calculator
obviously you can do a lot more than it
with it than this but the really nice
thing about Python and one of the things
people like about it is that you don't
need to do um setting up these variables
I don't need to say what type this is
going to be in other programming
languages you have to it's very
restrictive if I set this if I don't say
what this variable is if I don't say
that this is always this is going to be
an integer um it won't work but Python's
quite user friendly in that you don't
need to set everything up before you're
using it it's sort of very easy for
humans to understand what's going on
here let me add another block and we'll
go back to chat
GPD another thing we can do here is we
can create lists so we're going to talk
about this a little bit more with the
data structures but in this section
we're going to explain how you can
create lists of
information a lot of the power of python
comes from his ability to handle data
and manipulate data so in this case
we're creating a list so a list of
fruits apples bananas cherries with
lists what you do is you have the square
bracket on the end and you have um in
this case it's strings but this could
also be variables it could be integers
it could be any other data type which
you have in here and what we're doing is
listing these out so we're saying apples
bananas cherries we can then um access
these different elements in the list so
here we can say the first fruit in the
list is the fruits list the zero zero um
element in the list the key thing here
is that in computer science the counting
always starts from zero when we're
counting as humans we'll go 1 2 3 but
with um computer science the first
number is always zero um so this is the
zero um index of this list the last
fruit we can do a quite an interesting
um method to actually get the last item
in the list so let's say we start adding
more to this list um and it goes from
being two So currently it's 0 1 two as
the uh final element of the list but
let's say we add another one this won't
will no longer be the final element in
the list so we can get the final element
always by putting minus
one um you can also see we can do
manipulation to lists so in this case
we're adding an orange to the list with
this append function so we're taking the
list and we're applying a function to it
and adding
orange and then printing this updated
list of the fruit Roots variable so let
me run this one again and let's see what
we come out with so here we're saying
first fruit is Apple so first fruit
fruits zero is Apple last fruit last
fruit is minus one and this would be
Cherry updated list would be apple
banana uh cherry and then we're adding
the orange before we're printing so
we're essentially uh adding that orange
on and then printing so we see that as
well
maybe you could take a guess at what we
might see if we do another version of
this afterwards we can do this and we
can rerun it and see what this gives us
now and the answer is orange so
obviously it's found that final orange
and minus one still shows us the end of
the
list uh let's now look at conditional
statements so this is a way of checking
against limits so in some cases is you
might want to check if someone's uh if
you've got a database of people with IDs
and um they're trying to like get into
some uh bar or something and it's you're
not allowed in if you're over 18 if a
computer wanted to read the numbers from
the ID you want to check are these
people going to be over your age limit
or not so what you could do here is you
can set a variable as being an integer
of 18 and let's say you have or let's
say you have an age where someone's
younger let's say you have someone who's
17 who wants to try and come into this
um bar and you've created some computer
system to scan their ID and check if
they're old or not so you don't need to
use your eyes so what you could do here
is you can input the person's age that
you've collected from their bad from
their ID and then you can run your
script to say if this person's over 18
or under the key thing here is you can
use this um you can use this symbol
which is greater than and in this case
you're asking are they greater than or
equal to 18 um so if they're equal to 18
in this case they're going to be an
adult it was probably their birthday
like that year or that day so they're an
adult and then otherwise else you're a
minor so here you can say um the key
thing is to have these uh this colon at
the end and this being uh the new line
and then a and then a space and uh tab
space um and this is the way uh python
works so if I was to put it like this
it's not going to work you have to use
this indent when you're saying that this
is within this um conditional
check you can also do if um you can do
uh another you can do another check so
you could say if this um else if so you
can also do uh oh no l
if um some on um you know you could do
another LF check being something like
between 13 and 18 this person could be a
teenager so probably this is going to
yeah co-pilot again understanding what
I'm trying to do here so uh L if is
basically you're saying here if
someone's over 18 they're an adult if
they're between uh if that's not the
case you move on to the next conditional
check which would be an L if which is
else if the person's between 13 and 18
then this person is a
teenager else uh so if this person's not
over 18 they're not between 13 and 18
else they're a minor so if I rerun this
again we're going to see they're a
teenager so this is the way you can do
conditional statements to do some checks
um you could do this in many cases for
checks of input data you might want to
check if something's outside a limit if
someone's keyed in enough uh enough
numbers for them for it to be like a pin
number or a um check checking on
password information or if someone's
entered a correct email address you can
do checks like this on the data so very
common to use conditional statements for
things like
that uh next next block of
code Loops so um this is the final Block
in this script section and this is where
the real power of python comes in or any
coding for that matter so the real power
here is that I can I can actually cause
Loops to happen where it can repeat a
task for me many many times so I can
clean up data I could um I could fetch
different things and this is where you
know python can completely outperform
humans at certain tasks where it's like
a whole mass of tasks that we need to do
um if we need to do this manually we can
actually get python to do it all for us
much more efficiently
so here there's different types of Loops
we can use we can actually use four
Loops which is um where we have a number
and we have a range so here we're saying
for a certain number in the range 1
through to six we want to print that
number so the concept here is we have
the start of this range we have the end
of this range and for each number in
that range we want to
print for a while loop um this has to be
combined with some sort of increment or
decrement and the concept here is this
will repeat for Infinity until this um
until this limit here is reached so what
you have to make sure with this is that
you're moving it somewhere and it's
going to hit that limit eventually
otherwise this will run for Infinity so
you have to make sure sometimes you can
make that mistake where you're not doing
this correctly and it will just uh crash
so you have to make sure that when
you're using a y Loop in this case you
have a count of one you're saying while
count is less than or equal to five you
want to print the count and then you
want to increment the count by one so
each time you're going to go uh one uh I
mean you're going to go uh two then
three four and five until you get
through to the to the end where it's
greater than five and then it cancels
this and moves on to the next line of
code so let us run that and see what
happens so you see here for print number
in 1 to six as being the range we're
going to go one through to uh 1 through
to five even so it's going 1 2 3 4 5
this one here is starting on one so
we're printing out one to start with and
then it's going 2 3 4 five as well so
these are both doing the same thing okay
the next thing I want to show you is
around data structures data structures
is one of the most important Concepts in
Python so you have on the one side
scripts and algorithms which are very
important but you also have data
structures so if you are applying for a
job as a developer quite often there'll
be uh technical interview has two parts
one will be data structures one will be
algorithms potentially some other stuff
as well but those are like two of the
most common so here what we have is uh
again in the notion page um if you go to
the notion Page open up the data
structures link here we will see lists
once again so if we copy this across
we're going to once again understand how
lists uh work so we're going to just go
over those in a little bit more detail
so here what we have is a list of
strings again so different characters um
apple banana Cherry we can list those
strings by just calling this variable
which we've Associated the list to we
can access different items in the list
by actually um here having the square
bracket and the index of this list
within those so zero would be an index
for Apple we can add items to the list
with the append command and we can
actually remove items to the list so the
reverse of this by using the remove
command so let's have a look once again
um at how to run this so actually what
we can do is we can click run all or we
have some options over here with Jupiter
notebook to do execute the above cells
execute the
this cell and below so let's say I just
want to run this last cell this would be
a cell the blue um I can just click this
so the idea here is if I had some very
um if this was very complicated you
probably won't want to run the whole
Jupiter notebook again so here I'm just
running this
cell uh here we have the list of the
different fruits apple banana Cherry
we're saying first fruit is Apple that's
correct so we've got the index of zero
so we count from zero
um updated list of fruits where we've
used the append command so we've added
orange to the end of this list of fruits
uh so orange is there and then
afterwards we're actually taking this
list with the uh orange already added
and we're then removing the banana so
the banana is second in the list and
it's being removed here so it's not just
removing from the end of the list it can
remove from within if it finds the item
it
needs so let's look at the next type of
data structure list is the most basic
it's one of the most commonly used data
structures but we have another one which
is very uh commonly used so if we come
over to um okay so we're going to do TPP
next TPP are also very well used um but
this wasn't the one I was actually
referring to so um let's copy topples in
and so the topple the idea of topples is
that they're ordered and unchangeable so
they look a lot like a list but you see
they here have this um yeah more
circular bracket and what this means is
that you can't change the list if you
try to change it it would actually throw
you some error message so um let me run
this cell um over here you'll see here
topple of colors red green blue so we've
um pulled that out and access to the
topple item so we're seeing Zero and
we're finding that's red so again it
looks a lot like a list behaves a lot
like a list but let's actually uncomment
this thing here and let's cause an error
to happen so what we're doing is we're
trying to change the index zero which is
red into something which is yellow uh so
we can't do that with topples so let's
see what error we get here so we're
getting this type error so if you try
and do something that is you'll see this
a lot if you do if you do any Python
Programming more Python Programming in
the future you'll see error m is a lot
like it's it's uh all the time so um
it's all part of learning so what you
see here is I'm getting a type error
where I've tried to change what one of
these uh index items is in the topple
and you're not allowed to do that so
it's coming back to me with an error
message with error messages you really
want to read them so um Sometimes some
people will just see something and
they'll go like uh start trying to solve
it without even reading what the full
thing says but it normally it gives you
a very good idea of what's going wrong
um so you want to read the error
messages and here it says topples are
immutable you can't change the items
once the tupple is created so basically
it's saying that you know you can't you
can't do this topples uh you're not
allowed to do this anymore so um I can
comment this back out let's rerun the
code again and we won't have that issue
so we'll run this one it's fine so
basically very easy the thing with
topples is is I could change this really
easily if I wanted to into a list and
then let me try and uncomment this out
let's see what happens so let's run this
again and we're basically um oh and let
me obviously print this list as well so
I'm going to print this updated list so
again I'm using that Microsoft co-pilot
it just generates me this nice um quick
line of code and you'll see here that
okay because I'm using the list I can
now change this I'm not getting the
error message anymore so able to able to
um understand how topples work
there the next one very important in
Python very important to understand um I
would say which is dictionaries so
dictionaries are very nice data
structures that um you can use for
storing information nicely so what we
have here is
uh dictionary which is like the curly
brackets um and the way this works is
you can add like a profile here of a
person so this person's name is John
their age is 30 their city is New York
and uh the way this works is you have a
string it's always a string which would
be the key of the dictionary so this
here is how you um you you store a key
and then it has a value Associated it
associated with it so it's a key value
pair so the key is here is name uh the
value is John the key is age the value
is
30 so the way this um works is you can
send a lot of data around uh so we're
going to talk about it more apis these
send information in dictionaries and the
idea here is you can access some certain
properties of what information sent to
you let's say you just interested in the
name um you can access that very easily
so let me have a look at what we're
printing out here so basically we're
just printing the person dictionary out
here which would be the dictionary
itself so it looks like this exactly how
we see it in the code but what happens
if we want the person's name so the way
we can access items here is um so we're
saying print uh we've seen this many
times and the way we access this item is
through um typing in the key of what
we're looking for so in this case the
key is name
the value is JN so what we're doing is
we're pulling out from this dictionary
the John's name so name is equal to
John we can also add new key value pairs
by um just simply giving a new key and a
new value so the idea here is if you
want to add more data to this dictionary
you don't need to sort of rebuild it all
from scratch you can just add
information on very naturally and easily
so the updated dictionary is now looking
the same to there and then we have this
final one which is marital status which
is single so it's very flexible we can
just add data in if we need
to very nice um you can also then remove
items from the dictionary very easily so
I can say delete this person's age um
from this uh person variable and then we
go in there and you see name now John
City New York marital stat single so
we've removed his age so very easily
deleted data without rebuilding anything
or doing Loops um so very nice
dictionaries are used a lot so we're
going to use these some more as we
continue through the
course okay next I'll just very briefly
show you TP uh sets as well so
essentially sets are quite similar to
tles um in that you can't change the
items after the set has been created um
and they also don't allow dup
duplicates within the list or in the set
so here you have like 1 2 3 4 5 you
can't um add more duplicate values to
this set so I won't I won't go I won't
copy these into the Jupiter notebook
because we're not going to be using them
at all but um it's worth knowing there's
another data structure as well called
sets Okay next let's go back to our
notion page and from here um we're going
to start talking about open source
libraries so open source libraries is
one of the most amazing things about
programming in general um and that is
lots of people in the world who have
been programming have actually open
source their code meaning that if you
need to build something chances are lots
of other people have already built it
especially if it's very general um if
it's something like many people need
quite often someone has already built
that before and this can save us a lot
of time and we should be very grateful
to these people who have uh who support
open source projects so um essentially
we can reuse some of this code and all
we have to do is basically install the
code so what we're going to do here is
we're actually going to create some uh
filters for photographs so what we're
going to do is we're going to create
some of these ourselves we're going to
do everything manually and then we're
going to do things with an open source
Library so what I'm going to take here
is this block of code which is for
manually doing it and we're going to
look at how that really works so we're
going to go back to our VSS code block
and we're going to create
uh a new block down here so oops I'm on
the wrong thing here uh we're going to
create a new code block and we're going
to copy and paste this code in and I'm
going to talk you through this so This
is actually using some form of uh
Library anyway it's very rare actually
to be able to find something which is
for a task where it's completely uh
you're building it from scratch so this
is using actually some form of library
but the method we're actually going to
be doing is very manual
so the thing here is we want to set a
variable to be our image path where
we're going to load our image from so
what we have inside Lesson Four is we
already have a photo which is ready for
filtering a photo of this brick work
building and what we want to do is make
this gray scale so back in our script
we're going to need to put in here the
file path to where we stored this image
so the way to do this I'll show you the
way to do it on the Mac is essentially
we want to go to wherever we we stored
this and we want to go to our lesson and
we want to go down to the bottom here
and we want to click copy lesson four as
file path on Windows I think it's
actually easier than this but let me um
let me copy and paste that here so we
see our directory and then what we want
to do is put the file name in here so
photo for filtering so we want to put
that in here as well and make sure we
have the file extension right
jpeg so that's it so we've got users uh
yeah so this is where our file is then
what we're doing with this library is
we're saying image equals image open so
we're using this library to actually
kind of hold this image um in the memory
of um the
application then we're turning this into
an RGB so red green blue um I think it
might already be in that format but this
is just like a special check just to
make sure it's in the format we need it
to be um we're then basically creating a
copy of this which we're going to be
iterating over over over over over so
what we're saying is we're getting the
width and the height of this image from
some function which is available in this
pillow pill library that we're using um
with then using a loop so we're using
this four Loop where we're looking at
four and range before
to take the width of this image so this
is going to be the number of pixels so
it could be like 3,000 pixels 5,000
pixels I don't know um and then what
we're doing is we're iterating over
those each pixel um and then we're
putting another for Loop within this and
then for each row of the width we're
actually going through each column so
each pixel column and we're getting that
pixel so we're going image get the pixel
um at these coordinates we're then
basically getting the value which uh
would offset this pixel color so we're
using here a function which um is
apparently called a Luminosity method um
and we're then using this to calculate
how much we should offset the color by
to keep it to make it
grayscale we're then putting so we're
replacing that pixel at these
coordinates with the gray these
different RGB gray values which we want
to use so um yeah we're we're
essentially cutting out and replacing
the pixel line by line we're also then
going to show this image at the end so
what we want to do now is we want to
execute this and let's see what happens
so we're going to click this we're going
to see it's doing something it's running
and here we have the the image yay so
it's so it's converted this for us so
we've gone from our original one to our
new
one and it looks quite nice to me but
the purpose of this is to actually look
at the way in which um third party
libraries can make this much more
efficient so what you'll see here is
we're having to do a lot of this um
manipulation in here ourselves which
obviously we're not the first people to
ever have done this in the world of
programming but let's say in this case
what I really want is to actually um use
something a bit more simple so what you
see here is like this other this other
code is basically the same for the first
two lines and then we take it from there
with um let's take it from this
line so what you basically have is
another Library which we need here
called image Ops so what we want to do
is we actually want to import this so
again from P we're going to bring in a
whole Library which is for image
operations I guess and this has a
function in there for grayscale so this
will allow us to do hopefully the exact
same thing but with fewer lines of code
you always want to try and like minimize
the number of lines of code which you're
running so here we'll see we've
generated the same thing again and we've
gone from we've we've cut down from like
maybe eight lines of code to just one
okay so what I'm going to show you next
is a really important one in the world
of construction which is around data
visualization and data
manipulation um so if we go to the
notion page um and we come down a little
little bit we're going to see here
demonstration of data visualization
using pandas and map plot lib so these
are two libraries pandas is for data
manipulation in Python and matplot lib
is for data visualization so these are
two libraries that we can actually use
here and I want you to click this link
to take us to a chat GPT chat which is
explaining to us how we can get started
with these so the first thing I want you
to do is to copy and paste this block
here and come back to our um VSS code
and create a new code block just below
this I want you to post uh paste this in
and you're going to see here it's
importing the pandas Library as PD it's
also importing map plot lib uh Library
as
PLT so these are two libraries again two
open source libraries you can read the
documentation on exactly how these work
um
and what we're doing here is we're
loading in a data source and we're using
this pandas library and a function which
is already written within that Library
which has you know many lines of code
that someone's already created um and
we're using just a higher level function
which is read the CSV So within that
function there's going to be tons going
on but we are able because of this
library to just use a very simple
function to read that data so we're
going to use that feature um ourselves
so what I want you to do is I want you
to go back to where our um what where
you've saved Lesson Four and I want you
to go down to um copy this um I want you
to copy this path name so once you have
this copied I want you to paste this
into your string here so you see I've
got my file path um seemingly correct
and then what I want you to do is um
before we run this you can actually have
a quick look at the sample data so
you'll see here it's a CSV file but
essentially we have date a date column a
value column the date is a list of dates
and then each one has a different value
it's just dummy data really um but it's
going to allow us to look at how dat uh
data changes um can be visualized and
manipulated so the first thing we're
going to do is we're actually going to
run this um which is essentially just
going to load up this CSV into what we
call a data frame a pandas data frame
and the head is just going to be like
the top of that data frame so we're only
loading like the top chunk not
everything so it seems to take take us a
little while to load up here because um
probably this library is quite big um
but we've loaded it eventually so here
we have the top uh head which is the top
couple of rows I think this function is
more just to help you with checking um
that data is like loaded up and give you
a preview so yeah successfully loaded
this into what we call a data frame now
with this function so we've read our CSV
file and now we can work with it in
Python we can start doing some
interesting stuff with it so if we go
back to our chat GPT uh chat window um
let's have a look at this simple data
visualization that we can do so in this
case we're going to use the map plot lib
library and we're actually going to use
it to do some
visualization so once I've got this
loaded up uh once I've got that copied I
can paste it in and this is essentially
just going to make sure that the plots
are going to be shown in line in our
Jupiter notebook you don't always need
this in some cases but I'm just
including it here and then we're using
different functions from map plot lib to
create us a figure so this is going to
be um the sort of boundary let's say of
this this figure we're going to add data
uh to this uh add basically headings uh
or add our data ourself uh using the
keys and then add labels and plot this
this is basically going to show us a
preview at the end if I then run this
code um we're going to see our plot of
data so we've got here the X label is
dates y label um funnily enough you you
have the DAT uh the AIS down here but
it's black on the black background so
you can't see it particularly well but
this is date this is uh the different
values you have on the Y AIS so we've
got a nice visualization here that we've
done just with python okay guys great
job we've got finally got to one of the
really exciting moments now which is
we're going to start working with AI
using python so we're going to bring the
stuff we've been learning together um
what we're going to do is fire our
Jupiter notebook we're going to call a
large language model hosted by open AI
via an API uh and then we're going to do
some things with those results so what I
want you to First do is I want you to
register for an account with open AI uh
once you've done this I want you to head
over to where your API keys are stored
so you need to click uh API Keys you at
the time of recording this you're going
need to add a credit card to the open a
account they don't have a free AI model
right now um but this might change in
the future so maybe you'll be lucky but
um right now you need to add a credit
card detail credit card details um
you're going to click uh you're
basically going to click create new
secret key here and you can accept these
default options create secret key and
what this secret key is it's it's a way
in which open AI will authenticate that
this um API call is coming from you and
they also have a small uh Bill depending
on the number of tokens each time you
interact with them so the tokens would
be how many uh tokens you're sending
into the model and how many they're
returning um and this this API key um
we're going to be using this in our
Jupiter notebook so the important thing
is with API Keys is you have to keep
them secure you have to be very careful
with them um because they can be used to
rack up uh they can if these fall into
the hands of the wrong people they can
be used to um you know use your uh
credits or rack up a bill that you'll
have to then pay so be really careful
with where you store API keys don't go
storing them online or putting them on
any anything like GitHub um even if it's
password protected so I'm going to
deactivate mine after this be very
careful with your API key so what I want
to do is I want to go back to my Jupiter
notebook and I'm going to create a new
block of code down here which is where
I'm going to be doing my um scripts for
this AI um that I'm going to be
interacting with what I want to then do
is I want to go back to my notion uh I
want to scroll down a little bit and I'm
going to take this block of code which
is written here and this is basically
going to install some uh a library for
open AI so so far when we've been using
Jupiter notebooks uh We've not had to
install any Library like this um however
open ai's Library isn't native it's not
within uh Jupiter notebooks natur um
natively so we have to actually install
this ourselves to get to get set up
so we use this command pip install
openai we're going to be using this a
bit more in later uh lessons but this is
how you actually install um different
libraries into your
environment so you see this is this has
worked nicely it's installed it's giving
me a success message and what I'm going
to do is create another block below this
which is going to be where my script for
my um for my interactions with the open
AI API will go so you'll see here that
it's not actually a huge amount of code
that we need um they have made it quite
nice and easy actually to interact with
uh their their large language models so
um basically what I do here is I need to
um first import my open AI Library so
I've uh imported that up here and then I
need to set my API key so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to go back to my um
dashboard for open Ai and I'm going to
copy this uh and then I'm going to go
back to my vs Studio code and I'm going
to copy this into here so all I have to
do but like I was saying be very careful
with where this gets stored um you don't
want this ending up on the
internet then I want you to look at this
line so here what we're doing is we're
using uh the open a library um and what
this is is it's an object so we've not
spoken so much about objects so far but
open AI make it really nice and easy for
them uh for you to interact with their
their tools on a very high level so here
we just use the openi object and we
basically set the API key looks very
simple but obviously underneath this
there's a lot more going on uh then what
we're going to do is we're actually
going to stream back the out uh the
output so this API we're actually going
to stream information so it's not just
uh sending and waiting to receive back
we're actually going to send information
and it's going to stream back to us each
one of the tokens or the chunks is going
to stream back to us via the API we're
going to use their uh one of their
cheapest models here which is GPT 3.5 so
um not not one of the more advanced ones
just a cheap and cheap and simple one to
to get started and this is how you
interact with it so I'm setting some
messages here so I've set a system
message this is just telling the AI
basically what I want it to behave as so
this is actually from the openai
documentation on their website site as
just a simple quick start um chunk of
Code by basically saying uh that you're
a poetic assistant explain complex
programming concepts with creative flare
and here I'm saying compose a poem that
explains the concept of recursion in
programming okay we've not spoken about
recursion um actually but um we also
have to set the stream as being true if
we want this to stream back and then
basically what we're doing is receiving
back uh this stream and for each chunk
that's being received that's being
streamed back we're then basically
printing this so this is from the openai
documentation this is how the API Works
how they send information back okay now
let's just test this out so I'm going to
execute this code and let's see what
happens okay great so we've seen that
we're now streaming the message back and
we have some signs of life so great
job okay great job guys now what we're
going to do is we're going to start
building our first AI app for
construction we're going to start just
in Jupiter notebook just creating the
script um so we get a feel and
understanding for how we're building our
app and what we're going to do is we're
going to build an app which can look at
um Blueprints and create a bill of
quantities a table uh of all of the
quantities of the different elements
that are seen on that blueprint so you
can see the example we're actually going
to be using here and what we first want
to do is we want to to create a new
Jupiter notebook so we're going to put
this all in a new Jupiter notebook um
back in the same lesson folder so we're
still in lesson four but what I want us
to do is I want us to click this button
here which says new file and we're going
to either type or create a new file name
we're calling this one blueprint Ai and
it's still the Jupiter notebook file
extension so we can create this here um
you see we've we've created the file
this is where our codee's going to be
going so what we also want to do is we
also want to download this image so go
ahead and click the download button and
then what we're going to do is we're
going to copy that across from our
downloads into our lesson four so I'm
just going to move that across and I'm
going to copy this in so what I want to
see uh is the Les it's Lesson Four we
have our blueprint AI Jupiter notebook
and we have this PNG so it's an image
file it's not a PDF um this is what
we're going to get started on though uh
so what I want to do is go back to
blueprint uh the blueprint AI the
jupyter notebook and this is where my
code's going to be going so let's move
on to the next step which is basically
uh installing open aai again in this new
Jupiter notebook so I want to copy
across my code for doing that and I'm
going to execute this so we also want to
set which python um so this is a new dup
notebook so we want to set which python
uh version we want to use I'm going to
use this
3.10 um but feel free to use whichever
one you want I think um this is this is
the one that might be easiest though if
you want to follow along closely and so
I'm going to click a new code block as
well which is where my code for this app
is going to go and so let's copy this
new block of code in and we're going to
explain exactly what this one's
doing so here we go
so our API key let's let's get that in
first um let's just copy that across
from our previous Jupiter notebook so
let's put that one in
first and then I'm going to explain what
the this is so base 64 so this is
another Library we're going to be using
in this demo um and this this library is
basically going to be used to encode
images so we're going to take this PNG G
file we have here and in order for us to
send this to a large language model or a
multimodal uh AI model which is what
we're going to do um we need to encode
this image and we're going to basically
turn it into like a binary format so
base 64 is a type of binary like it's
like raw data rather than um this PNG
file we're going to turn this into a
different file format which this m
multimodal AI can understand and read
basically building that multimodal AI um
meant that my understanding is that um
open AI which is the which is the
provider we're going to be using trained
on many many different images they
basically turned so many images that I
guess are publicly available on the
internet into into raw binary base 64
data and then they created that their AI
model on that binary data so um this is
what we need to send in we send in Bas
64 and it kind of understands what that
image is just from the raw data itself
it's really quite amazing if you think
about it uh so we still have our openai
object up here which we're going to be
using we've set our API key um in this
following the documentation so this may
change in the future so just be aware
that um you know open AI always I guess
trying to make things easier in terms of
using their
API so here's the path to our image so
what I want you to do is actually to
make sure that you're also still using
the right path so you can go reveal in
finder um if you're using a Mac and
basically you can check here that you're
actually using the correct um you can
you can make sure that you're using the
correct file path here so I'm just going
to copy this across although I'm pretty
sure I'm using the right
one um so this is the image path we're
going to be using using to actually pull
this image out and here we're doing B 64
encode the image and we're pointing it
at where this image is so this is going
to this variable is now going to hold
the base 64 string so it's a string of
characters a bit like this is a string
this will also be a string base 64
image the large language model we're
going to be using here is actually GPT
40 um and this is one of the latest
models that they've released which can
which has this multimodal aspect it can
understand image data as well and from
the documentation this is the way in
which we should interact with this AI
model so we're setting here some
instructions so we're saying provide a
takeoff of the quantities from this
engineering drawing returning as a table
so we want the table back and here is
how we send our image so we send this
image URL um dictionary uh element
and basically this is where that data
goes this is where that string goes so
this is just following the open AI
documentation um so you just need to
make sure that it's it's following that
I'm going to stream back the response
again and so I'm using this Chunk in
stream method I like to use the
streaming because then you don't have to
wait and uh you get to see the results
as they sort of print out so again doing
the same method here so let's see what
happens let's see if we generate our
um our table of
quantities so it seems to be working
it's slightly slower as you can see than
the than the GPT 3.5 but how amazing is
this it's actually printing out uh the
table that we wanted to see of all of
these different elements on the drawing
so we we're going to do much more than
this but congrats guys we've just built
our first AI app for construction
okay great job guys I know that this
wasn't the easiest lesson and we've
covered a lot of things this is going to
be the most challenging lesson actually
in the whole course so if you followed
along um then great if you have if
there's still some things you're not
sure on please do go back and rewatch
those and don't feel afraid to like
pause and just double check and check
online or check with chat GPT or
something like this or message in the
Discord because I know we have covered a
lot in this lesson in the next lessons
it's going to be slightly easier but
what we're going to be doing is perhaps
more rewarding because what we're going
to be doing is we're actually going to
be um publishing and we're going to be
building more of these different apps
based on all this stuff which we've been
learning so far so in the next lesson
what we're going to do is we're going to
take the script we've just created and
we're going to turn it into a web app
which we're going to publish online so
that other people are able to find and
discover and use uh our AI model so
thank you very much for listening and
see you in the next lesson